if you enjoy cheap wine and you blend it
it might open a whole new world for you
[Music]
there's a very clear difference here
this is easier to drink this one's a
little smoother when you drink it this
one's sweeter this one's a little
juicier this one is more tart this one
has a little bit more of a bite to it
this one packs more of a punch has like
that dry sharpness like when I drink
this I'm just like it just seems that
blending the wine subdues the bitterness
and tartness drinking it on its own
this one is tastier I like this one more
not that you should chug wine but if I
had to chug wine I would chug the
blended wine I love cheap wine and I
prefer this one
[Music]
one is much nicer this is more
sickly-sweet this one's better your and
muted down it's just less flavorful than
this wine I am surprised I don't like
the blended white wine more are you sure
you didn't get these backwards so I'm
getting a third glass because I'm not I
don't believe you
I think that you meant mixed these up so
this one's blended this one is blended
these two okay
I believe you these two tastes alike why
do I prefer the unblended one this one
is Chris Berg this one is fruitier this
one is much prettier
I concur this one is more like it's more
refreshing this one has more flavor I
think the thing I liked about the red
wines that were blended was it took the
tartness out of the wine whereas with
white wine I like the tartness a bit
more this one sucks
don't don't believe me here sure blended
red not blended wait blend another glass
bring it in here blend it
we're know we're gonna have three on the
table keep rolling we're gonna have
three on the table bring another oh yes